wolfgang fishes sticks tell the epic
tale of a solo skipper sailing in the
open sea but she soon confronted with a
terrible dilemma through that
confrontation the film explores the
themes of immigration and
responsibilities confirmed but I won't
leave it around moral justice in
difficult times is a theme running
through each of this year's finalists
for the lux film prize in Benedict
ellingson's woman at war we follow the
protagonists personal battle against
destructive greed and her call for
society to rise up while at the same
time following her own personal journey
as a woman for the first time in the
history of the lux film prize a
documentary makes this year's final
selection with the other side of
everything neither too religious film
portrays a woman whose own story mirrors
that of her country and Europe miss
rosemary from using technicals of the
body's journeys the sequin adults-only
nurse funeral edo poster priam evilly
intuitive after and through her eyes we
see the political upheavals of the 20th
century thanks to the European
Parliament support the films have been
subtitled in all 24 of the --use
official languages in order to help them
reach a wider audience all over Europe